Fred wrote this really serious song
about about Ralph and I actually thought
it was pretty good yeah it was and uh I
just thought the guy who could actually
make this emotional would be Pat Monahan
because I love your voice and I love the
way you sing thanks and I mean your
songs always evok so much emotion so I
figured well okay I'll send it off to
Pat and see if he has any interest in
maybe doing this yeah it was very
because you know look like I I really I
really dug rough a lot you know we I've
seen Ral half a dozen times or more and
every time he was uh very kind to me and
so uh when he surprisingly was not here
anymore I was like man I uh I haven't
seen you guys in so many years like I I
never would have thought that he would
be one of the guys I wouldn't see again
so uh I was happy to be involved in
anyway I'll tell you Pat I think you
nailed it I I mean I listen to it I I I
teared up last night so it hit all the
right cords of me but of course I love
Ralphie boy so so I'm going to play the
song now okay Fred you ready to hear it
I am very honored that Pat did it and uh
I was so impressed when I heard it
because he really didn't do anything to
the song except be honest with it he
just he just brought himself to the
project and uh thanks thanks for doing
that yeah of course Pat I'm I'm shocked
that uh I'm I'm surprised Fred doesn't
scare you you don't look uh the least
bit nervous around him but good for you
oh I'm scared you
are yeah when you when when we sent you
a Fred composition I went oh [__] poor
Pat if he [__] this up he's got to
answer to Fred all right anyway I don't
want to break the mood but this is
really beautiful for you to have done
for Ralphie boy we all hail you for
doing it I know you're busy as hell but
uh thank you is what I want to say
before I play this here it is this is
called Ralph song Pat
[Music]
manahan goodbye my dear friend Ralph
goodbye
goodbye my dear friend Raph
goodbye I'll never feel the same about
anyone again goodbye my dear friend Raph
goodbye nothing in the
world certain how could it be never
believed what we had would ever
die
yesterday your essence sailed
away into the silent Holy
Night you been called home cuz nobody
gets to
stay the place where you once stood is
now an empty space
you cannot measure it what a sacred
treasure is and all the secret dreams we
had to get left
behind by my dear friend Ralph
goodbye goodbye my dear friend Ralph
goodbye there will never
be any one like you
again goodbye my dear friend Ralph
goodbye beautiful wow wow what a tribute
to Ralphie boy he would be beside
himself he knew you did that Pat yeah
was that's all Fred's work I uh I just
did U our version of it good work Fred
man my friend
good yeah Fred yeah don't don't hurt Pat
he did he did your here's the deal when
I heard it uh I mean there are some
people when you give them something they
always got to put their fingerprints all
over it and when they do they just mash
the [__] out of it they just [__] it up
and Pat didn't do that he enhanced it he
kept it pure he just did such a great
job cool thanks yeah you did too I don't
mean to ruin the mood but have you two
discussed the royalty split there's
going to be tremendous amount of income
off of this thing and uh
how's that all work I
mean